اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بوعيده محادثاته مع قاده
النيتو في ليتوانيا بايدن في هيلثينكي
لحضور قمه مع قاده دول الشمال الاوروبي
يؤكد على ان الناتو اصبح الان اكثر قوه
بعد انضمام فنلندا
يقول انه لا شكل لديه في ان اوكرانيا
ستصبح عضوا بعد الحرب
مكتب حقوق الانسان التابعه للامم المتحده
يقول ان 87 شخصا على الاقل بعضهم من عرقيه
المساليد دفنوا في مقبره جماعيه في غرب
دارفور بالسودان مشيرا الى ان لديه
معلومات جديره بالثقه عن مسؤوليه قوات
الدعم السريع عن ذلك وداعيا الى اجراء
تحقيق سريع وشامل
قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تشون حمله
مداهمات واعتقالات في عدد من مدن الضفه
الغربيه واشنطن تجدد دعوتها لتجنب
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب بما في ذلك طرد
الفلسطينيين من بيوتهم في القدس
وبنجفير يدعو واشنطن لعدم التدخل في شؤون
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الامم المتحده تعلن ان حوالي 735 مليون
انسان على مستوى العالم عانوا من جوع مدقع
العام الماضي نضحت لنا هذا الرقم اعلى
بكثير مما كان عليه قبل جائحه كورونا ما
يهدد بعرقله تحقيق هدف العالم بالقضاء على
الجوع بحلول عام 2030
الى اللقاء